The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: One
of the ways to think
about the American
musical, generally,
is to recognize that it's
a distinctive, maybe even
a unique American form and with
the Western movie, the two most
distinctive contributions
that Hollywood has made
to the art of movie making.
Listen to this entry on
musicals, the very beginning
of the entry on musicals from
The Oxford Companion to Film.
"The history of
the screen musical
is essentially that of
the American musical.
The outstanding
examples of the genre
have been made in Hollywood,
and only the American industry
has consistently
produced musicals
throughout the sound era."
The book was published
in the early '70s,
just as Hollywood movies were
undergoing the transformation
I've alluded to.
"Indeed with the
Western, the musical
could be claimed as Hollywood's
outstanding contribution
to the history of cinema."
So that's a good
context for thinking
both about the Westerns we'll
be talking about in the next two
weeks and about the musicals
we're thinking about this week.
Perhaps before we
go any further,
it would be useful for me
to give a very quick talk
about the problem of
definition because there
is music in almost all films.
How do we distinguish a
musical, a true musical,
from a film that contains music?
And the simplest answer is
also the most obvious one.
We would embrace a
definition, I think,
that would say that a film
in which song and dance are
so essential that to remove them
would leave virtually nothing
means you're watching a musical.
And that would
distinguish it then
from many, many films
in which musical
elements may be present,
even musical performances
may be present, but they
are not at the very essence
of what the film is.
And the film is not entirely
dependent upon those elements.
So a simple,
straightforward definition.
One way we can measure the
significance, the centrality,
of the musical and
also of the Western,
because the numbers are somewhat
similar for the Western--
the centrality of the
musical to the studio system
is to look at the numbers.
And between 1927 and 1947,
just over 900 musical films,
were made.
That's approximately
48 films a year.
That's roughly 10% of
the total production
of movies during that
period were musicals.
And one of the things
it shows, of course,
is how steady the
audience for musicals
were, how stable the system
became relatively quickly,
allowing for the elaboration
and repetition of the fuller
exploration of this
particular genre of movie.
And you can recognize
the decline, too.
There are people who would
argue that the musical,
in its exuberance, and the
American musical especially,
in its exuberance and optimism,
represented essentially
a pre-war value.
And there are people who
say, well, after the war,
the musical began to decline.
There are other explanations
for why the musical began
its decline, and
the primary one is
the one I've already implied.
The studio system
was breaking down,
and the captive audience
of millions and millions
of people who went to the movies
every week was disappearing.
But in the period
between 1949 and 1958,
a much briefer period, only
23 films a year were made.
They were still a significant
proportion of the Hollywood
output, but you can
understand-- you
can see the tremendous decline.
And then in the period between
'59 and 1980, only seven
films that could be
named musicals a year.
The genre is virtually--
not exactly extinct,
but it's now a specialty item.
And musicals
continued to be made,
but they are hardly part of
the regular fare of moviegoers.
So we can think of
the musical as one
of the distinctive expressions
of the Hollywood studio era.
And in their optimism and
in their-- maybe in even
in their relative reluctance
to engage directly
with political and
social questions,
they express a certain value
or a certain perspective
that particularly illuminates
the remarkable entertainment
industry that Hollywood became.
I want to just say a very few
words about the dominant themes
in these films.
They're what you might expect
from this combination of music
and comedy.
One recurring topic is the
theme of show business.
Many musical films
have as their plot--
there's a kind of subgenre
of musical films devoted
to the question of
putting on a show.
And the drama of this
subcategory of musicals
is you begin at the beginning
with the cast being assembled,
and you watch the
difficulties, the internal
and public difficulties,
that the show
has getting on the boards.
And one very common-- this
is derived, in some sense,
from forms of
musical performance
that existed on Broadway
before they migrated
to Hollywood, before they
were adopted and adapted
by Hollywood.
And what's embedded in
this show business theme,
for example, are larger themes.
And one of them is the
theme of community.
In other words, you'll see
a very concrete and dramatic
articulation or dramatization
of these principles
in Singin' in the
Rain this evening.
All of the themes I'm talking
about now you will find,
I think, expressed, dramatized
with great authority and wit
in Singin' in the Rain.
So the idea is that this
putting on of a show
means that you have a community
of people who have to get along
together, and what is discovered
in the tensions and problems
that begin to develop?
There are things
that have to do,
if we jump down in my
categories to the next one,
not to high culture popular
but to the next one, to class
or position-- you can
see that, in some sense,
the theme of community leads
also then, at least implicitly,
into an interest in the
relative questions of hierarchy,
as against questions of talent.
In other words, I'm
the important singer,
but my understudy
has the better voice.
What's the tension there?
What's going to happen there?
And you'll see how this theme,
with wonderful comic energy,
plays itself out in
Singin' in the Rain.
But what I want you to recognize
as embedded in that theme
is what we-- not only
in what I'm calling
the theme of community,
or the theme of class,
social class or social
hierarchy or social position,
and the tension between
individual talent
and social position, which
repeatedly expresses itself,
at least implicitly, in these
music-- what does this say?
That the musicals do
have, at some level,
a kind of implicit
political subject matter,
that they're often
about democracy
or about how to get along.
And in fact, during
the most recent crisis
of partisan disagreement
in Congress,
I was thinking, gee, if I could
send them a couple of musicals,
and if they pay
attention to them,
maybe they could get along, too.
Probably too hopeful an idea.
But there is a political
dimension to the drama,
even to the confined drama
of putting on a show,
that some very good musicals
bring to the surface.
Another central
theme is the one I
skipped over-- the
conflict, often a tension
or a conflict between
high and popular culture,
with Hollywood and
the musical film
almost always standing on
the side of the popular as
against the moribund and
pretentiously sclerotic,
old-fashioned older forms.
And they often create a kind
of cartoon of the older forms
in order to celebrate
their own energy.
But this tension is a
recurring one in musicals,
and you'll see versions
of these themes
in both the musicals that are
on our roster for this evening.
Finally, implicit in
what I've been saying
is the theme of
convention and restraint
versus spontaneity, energy, what
we think of as "the natural."
And I'll say more
about this tonight
when we talk about the
dance sequences in Singin'
in the Rain.
But at the moment,
just let me emphasize
the extent to which this
principle of a kind of conflict
between what is handed
down, what is conventional,
what is expected
and what is dictated
by your spontaneous needs,
desires, a sense of joy
is a constant source
of tension and energy
in many, many
musicals and is one
of the central organizing
principles of Singin'
in the Rain.
And we'll come back
to that tonight
when I talk more
fully about that film.
Well, what I'd like
to do with the time
I have left is try to
illustrate in a certain way two
different things.
And they're partly in conflict,
and therefore, in some sense,
I'm simplifying, but it's an
intellectually justifiable
simplification.
What I want to do
simultaneously is give you
a kind of brief sense of
the history of the musical
but also a sense of
the different flavors
within the broad category of the
musical that might be possible.
This is obviously an impossible
task in 30 minutes or so,
but we're going to
accomplish it anyway
in a very reduced and
crystallized way, I think.
As you might imagine, the
central impetus for the musical
occurred technologically
with the advent of sound.
As soon as sound became
possible, people were thinking,
ah, we can sing in the movies.
Music is going to be
important in the movies.
And of course, that
was in fact the case.
The very first sound film, The
Jazz Singer, was about singing.
It had ten interpolated
songs in it
and only two lines of dialogue.
In it, Al Jolson, the
famous blackface performer,
played a performer in blackface,
a Jew actually, a white man,
who played a black,
most famously, on stage.
In this particular film,
he plays a religious
family's-- the son of
a religious family,
of a Jewish family,
who wants to sing jazz,
not to be a cantor
in the synagogue.
And his father's
very angry at him
because he thinks he's
betraying-- and can you
see embedded there is the
theme of, in a certain sense,
high religious culture
versus popular culture?
In the very first film
that interpolated music,
that theme is already present.
And in 1928, Jolson
again appeared
in a film called The Singing
Fool that made a great success.
And what then followed in
1929 were a whole series
of musical films, of films
that incorporated music,
including, in 1929, a film
called The Broadway Melody
of 1929.
And it contained
a backstage story,
like the one I've
already described,
about two sisters from
vaudeville who tried to reach
Broadway and star on Broadway.
And therefore, the
putting on of a show
is one of the implicit subjects.
But this form of
early musical was
derived from Broadway
in a very direct way.
And it often did not
have a coherent plot.
It often involved a series of
singing and dancing numbers
interspersed with comic dialogue
of some kind-- literally
a revue, not a play.
And then some
versions of the revue
began to have more systematic
plots, animated, I think,
generated by this theme
of putting on a play.
And The Broadway Melody of 1929
was an astonishing success.
It was partly because it was the
most fully success-- most fully
musicalized film
up to that time.
And it was so popular, it was--
incidentally, the songs written
for it were written by
Herb Nacio Brown and Arthur
Freed, the two people who
are at the center of Singin'
in the Rain.
Nacio Brown's songs are
in Singin' in the Rain,
and Arthur Freed, of course,
is the great executive producer
responsible for more of the
great musicals in the Hollywood
era than any other figure.
So they begin even that
early, at the very earliest
stages of the medium's history.
And so then Broadway Melody was
so popular and so successful
that in 1930, 70
new musicals were
produced, mostly in imitation.
And the film won an
Oscar for Best Film.
So it immediately
established musical films,
films with music, song, and
singing and dancing in them
as a central category.
Most early musicals were revues
of this sort, very early ones.
They combined-- they
used Broadway, Hollywood,
vaudeville, and radio
stars, incorporated them
in lavish musical numbers
interspersed with sketches.
And again, they were not
necessarily coherent plots,
and most of them
didn't even attempt
to present a coherent plot.
This kind of film, more
coherently plotted,
remained a subcategory
of musicals
all the way through the
history of musicals.
And that's why I want to qualify
the idea that I'm giving you
a history.
I am giving you a
kind of history,
but it's a complicated
history because the forms
I'm talking about
don't completely
disappear and get supplanted
by the more advanced forms.
They live together
simultaneously.
And the question of whether
one is a more advanced form
than another might be
debatable, although I think
there are distinctions,
as you'll see, that do
suggest that there's a kind
of progression, an increasing
understanding of
what it would mean
to make a musical film
that was truly coherent,
that wasn't simply presenting
us with the joy of song
and dance in a way unconnected
to story or character.
But it remained a subcategory.
This revue remained
a subcategory
of musical films all the
way through the history
of the form.
And in 1946, one of the most
remarkable versions of this
was made.
It was called Ziegfeld Follies.
And again, it was
based on-- it was
a film about-- a nostalgic film
about a Broadway phenomenon,
but it was a fully
integrated film.
--of a form that was
popular in the United States
but even much more popular in
Europe-- the stage operetta.
It wasn't a full opera.
It was often a kind of
smaller comic drama that
involves singing and dancing.
And they were called operettas
because they were understood
to be smaller versions of opera,
more amusing, less demanding
versions of opera, I suppose,
less pretentious and tragic
versions of opera.
And there were a number
of European directors
who, when they immigrated
to the United States,
brought their distinctive
feel to the making
of early musicals.
And some of the most
powerful, artistically
powerful early musicals
fell into the category
not of the revue
but of the operetta.
And I want to show you
one version of such a film
now, one of my favorite passages
from the great director Rouben
Mamoulian in 1932, a scene from
Love Me Tonight, made in 1932.
It's a long sequence.
I may have to skip some of it,
but let me set it up for you.
In this film, Maurice
Chevalier, whose English
is so terrible that you'll have
trouble understanding him--
his French accent is
so deep at this point.
He became much better at
English because, as some of you,
I hope, realize, he
became a great star
in the English-speaking
world as well as in France.
But in this film-- this is
one of his earliest films,
if not his first English
film, and he plays,
even though he's
very well-dressed
here-- he plays a working man,
a middle class-- a tailor.
He plays a tailor.
And he owns a tailor
shop in Paris.
And in this opening scene,
one of the men that he-- one
of the aristocrats
whose clothing he makes
comes in to be fitted out
for his wedding outfit,
and Maurice Chevalier does so.
The plot of the film
depends upon the fact
that Maurice Chevalier, this
middle class tailor who's
trying to make a living
in Paris in his shop,
is brought into the ambit
of an aristocratic family,
of a royal family.
And because there
is an aristocrat
for whom Maurice Chevalier has
made a great many suits who
owes him money, and
Maurice chases him
to his castle in the
country, trying to find,
trying to recover his money, and
romantic entanglements ensue.
And the larger part of the film
actually involves a romance
across social class between
this Parisian tailor
and a princess played by
Jeanette MacDonald, one
of the great musical
stars of the studio era.
So here is a scene from very
early in Love Me Tonight.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-All right.
[WHISTLING]
[MUSIC - FELIX MENDELSSOHN,
"WEDDING MARCH"]
-Maurice, it's beautiful.
DAVID THORBURN: Can
you make it any louder?
Can you hear it?
-You make a work of art.
-Work of art for
your sweetheart.
-Oh, it's like poetry in a book.
Oh, a beautiful large book.
-[INAUDIBLE].
The romance of the season--
-So clear like wind.
Oh, me.
[LAUGHING]
-Oh.
Oh [INAUDIBLE].
-Oh, you're a magician.
-Isn't it romantic?
-(SINGING) My face is glowing.
I'm energetic.
The art of sewing I find poetic.
My needle punctuates
the rhythm of romance.
I don't give a stitch
if I don't get rich.
A custom tailor who has no
custom is like a sailor.
No one will trust him.
But there is magic in
the music of my shears.
I shed no tears.
Lend me your ears.
Isn't it romantic?
Soon I will have found
some girl that I adore.
Isn't it romantic?
While I sit around, my
love can scrub the floor.
She'll kiss me every hour,
or she'll get the sack.
And when I take a shower,
she can scrub my back.
Isn't it romantic?
On a moonlight night,
she cook me onion soup.
Kiddies are romantic--
DAVID THORBURN: Would
you freeze it one second?
Very quick observation.
I can't interrupt
too often because I
have a lot of clips to
show you, and they're
more important
than my commentary.
But let me remind you that
even at this very early stage
in the history of
the musical, look at
how visually
sophisticated Mamoulian,
and pay attention as the
film, as the sequence goes on.
But look at how he's working
with the mirrors here
and how it's
doubling-- what it does
to your sense of
perspective and your sense
of the environment of the shot.
This is a visually
sophisticated, very thoughtful,
artistically manipulated camera,
and it's Mamoulian's work.
So very early in the
history of the musical,
we're already getting
visually subtle effects.
-(SINGING)-- we'll
have a troupe.
We'll help the population.
It's a duty that
we owe to France.
Isn't it romance?
-Isn't it romantic?
Da, da, da, da.
A very catchy strain.
Isn't it romantic?
Da, da, da.
Oh, I forgot my cane.
Oh, thank you very much.
-I better fix your tie.
-Da, da, da, da,
da, da, da, da--
-Goodbye.
Isn't it romantic?
Da, da, da, da, da.
-Taxi.
-Oh no, I need some air.
Isn't it romantic?
--[WHISTLING] At last
I've got a fare.
-Railroad station!
-[WHISTLING]
-Not too fast.
I hate to take a chance.
-Isn't it romance?
Isn't it romantic?
[HONKING]
--[WHISTLING] Drive
around the town.
-Isn't it romantic?
[HONKING]
-Da, da, da, da-- I think
I'll take that down.
-[WHISTLING]
-A, B, A, G, F, E,
D, C, C, A, B-flat.
Isn't it romantic?
Da, da, da, da.
I like the noise as well.
Isn't it romantic?
[SINGING CONTINUES]
Isn't it romance?
Isn't it romantic?
[SINGING CONTINUES]
-Isn't it romance?
-Isn't it romantic?
DAVID THORBURN: That's
Jeannette MacDonald.
-Music in the night, a
dream that can be heard.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN: OK.
Can we have the lights also?
Thank you.
All right.
I hope you enjoyed
that lovely sequence.
That device is called
a "pass-along song."
I've written it on the board.
And I won't say
more about how witty
and wonderful the film
is, except to suggest
that apart from its wonderfully
amusing and witty qualities,
I hope you implicitly
recognized why I took the time
to describe the plot to you
because what does the music do?
What does this song do in
this early part of the film?
It predicts the plot.
It predicts the story.
It carries the story into the
countryside to the very castle
where the plot will take Maurice
from Paris later in the story.
And not only that.
What is dramatized by the
way in which this song moved
from tailor to aristocratic
well-dressed man to composer,
artist to cab driver to soldier
to gypsy to Princess Jeanette?
And also that it covers physical
territory as well as-- it
crosses social barriers.
It crosses particular
social classes.
It crosses
differences of gender.
It crosses ethnic difficult--
what does it say about music?
Music creates community.
Music is democratic.
Music can overcome
barriers, which
is going to be ultimately the
message of the film itself.
So it's an immensely
subtle, crystallized moment
in the film, and
it has all kinds
of powerful thematic
implications for later
in the film, apart
from the fact that it's
a wonderfully rich introduction
to the primary character
and to the joys of music.
Reality is, however, that
until the advent in something
like 1933 of work
by Busby Berkeley,
the great choreographer
and director working,
at this stage, primarily for
the Warner Brothers Studio
did we begin to see forms
of the movie, forms of film,
forms of cinema that were
uniquely adapted to the nature
of music itself.
That is to say, Busby Berkeley
became a legend in Hollywood
for the immense extravagance
and elaborateness
of his dance numbers and
of his production numbers.
They were an
elaboration of something
that was popular in
the Broadway theater
before the advent of movies.
But what Berkeley did was take
this tendency of the Broadway
theater and cinematize
it in a certain way.
And we can get some
sense of what Berkeley
was like, what
Berkeley's work is like,
by talking about the way in
which he created a new attitude
toward film spaces.
He loved to create receding
arches and doorways and even
waterfalls and to
destroy what we
might call "theatrical space"
by exploring the camera's powers
coupled with the power of
editing, the power of editing
now linked to rhythms of music.
So he created, essentially, a
choreography for the camera.
No seated audience could have
had the views and experiences
that the Busby
Berkeley production
numbers began to provide.
And there's a moment in
Singin' in the Rain tonight
that explicitly recalls this
tradition of the musical.
There's a moment in which
a character in the film
has a megaphone, and the
front of the megaphone
dissolves into a circle
of costumed dancers
in a sequence called
"Beautiful Girls."
That's the name of the number.
And that whole number is an
homage to this Busby Berkeley
tradition.
Well, there were
certain disadvantages
to the Berkeley strategy.
One of them was that especially
in the extremity with which he
began to pursue his
expressive aims,
he began to sort of
dematerialize his women.
He began to objectify them.
And many of his films, many
of his production numbers,
literally objectify parts of
a woman's body, especially
breasts and bottom and legs.
And there's almost, in a certain
sense, a kind of dehumanizing
impulse in which the
human figures, especially
when he used-- he
often would use cameras
that would rise very high.
He invented a shot called
the "Berkeley top shot."
Often cut a hole in the
ceiling of the places
in which they were filming
so he could move up higher.
And he would film
from so far above
that the individual lineaments
of bodies would disappear,
and only the patterns
that they made appeared.
What he anticipated was MTV and
forms of expressive filmmaking
that severs a
musical experience,
or an audiovisual experience
animated by music,
driven by music, from subject,
from plot, from story.
In other words,
there's something
in one sense very
visionary about what
Busby Berkeley was doing.
But of course, he was doing
this often in the middle--
always in the
middle of films that
had stories and characters.
And one of the
issues in his films
were the production numbers were
far more lavish, interesting,
and witty and
aesthetically energized
than the stories
that carried them.
And in a certain
sense, the stories
were really the
platform to generate
these kinds of performances.
So the films were not as
aesthetically coherent
as one would like, but they
were full of these astonishingly
expressive musical numbers,
audiovisual experiences.
And let me just show you
one that will give you
a sense of his extravagance,
of his extremism,
in a certain sense, although
that's part of the pleasure we
take in how far he can go.
There's something deeply
camp, deeply campy
about Busby Berkeley's
choreography.
And he reveled, he reveled
in these kinds of gestures.
But here is one
of the most famous
of the-- although not by far
the most extreme or ridiculous,
of these kinds of gestures
from a film Berkeley made
in 1933 called 42nd Street.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-(SINGING) Say I know
a bundle of humanity.
She's about so high.
And I'm just driven to
insanity when she passes by.
She's a snooty little cutie.
She's been so hard to kiss.
DAVID THORBURN: See how we
started a theatrical space.
-And then I'll tell her--
DAVID THORBURN: Dick Powell,
one of the great performers
of the studio era,
both musical and stage.
- --healthy, and
you've got charms.
It'd really be a sin not
to have you in my arms.
I'm young, healthy,
and so are you.
When the moon is in the sky,
tell me what am I to do?
Say-- If I could hate
ya, I'd keep away.
But that ain't my nature.
I'm full of vitamin A, say!
I'm young and healthy,
so let's be bold.
In a year or two or three,
maybe we will be too old.
I'm young and healthy,
and you've got charms.
It'd really be a sin not
to have you in my arms.
I'm young and healthy,
and so are you.
When the moon is in the sky,
tell me what am I to do?
If I could hate
ya, I'd keep away.
But that ain't my nature.
I'm full of vitamin A, say!
I'm young and healthy,
so let's be bold.
In a year or two or three,
maybe we will be too old.
-I'm young and healthy,
and you've got charms.
It would really be a sin not
to have you in my arms, dadum.
-I'm young and healthy,
and so are you.
When the moon is in the sky,
tell me what am I to do?
-If I could hate you,
honey, I'd keep away.
But that ain't my nature.
I'm full of vitamin A. Whoa--
I'm young and healthy, so let's
be bold.
In a year or two or three,
maybe we will be too old.
DAVID THORBURN: The
Berkeley top shot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
See how he's moved to a
kind of abstraction here?
-If I could hate
ya, I'd keep away.
But that ain't my nature.
I'm full of vitamin A, say!
I'm young and healthy,
so let's be bold.
In a year or two or three,
maybe we will be too old.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN: You
think there might
be something almost grotesque
about those final images?
On the other hand,
can you also see how
in a system that is censored,
in which women are not
allowed to be seen on
a bed without one foot
at least on the
floor, in which there
is a kind of sexual energy
and a kind of testing
of boundaries running through
this kind of display as well.
We're running out
of time, and I have
another even more
magnificent sequence
to show you to finish
out this attempt
to give you at least a quick
flavor of the varieties
of experience available
in the musical
before we look at a fully
integrated musical this evening
with Singin' in the Rain.
Let me say very quickly
then, to jump to the bottom,
the final aspect of this is what
Arthur Freed and his cohorts
articulated as the idea of a
musical that would integrate
sufficiently music and dance
with character and story
in a way that would be coherent.
And the musicals made under
Arthur Freed's direction, often
called the "Freed
Unit" at MGM, tried
to satisfy this criterion.
They were, in many
ways, more coherent
in terms of the relation
between the singing
and the dancing and the story
than these earlier forms
were, although they were
often less imaginatively
expressive in some cases,
although this is not true,
I think, of Singin' in the Rain.
But there is another stage to
mention in this development
or evolution, and it's
one of the most important
in the history of the
Hollywood musical.
And it has to do with the
partnership between Fred
Astaire and Ginger Rogers,
mostly at the RKO studios.
They made nine films together
between 1933 in 1939 at RKO.
And they introduced
another element
into the musical film
that is then, I think,
incorporated in a certain degree
in the so-called integrated
musical of MGM.
So my last example
this afternoon
comes from the
great Astaire-Rogers
musical, Top Hat.
And let me set
the stage for you.
Get ready to show it because
we're running out of time.
The situation is this--
and it dramatizes even more
fully the idea that there are
potentially sexual tensions,
sexual themes embedded in the
experience of watching a song
and dance musical.
What the Astaire-Rogers
musicals brought
to the table that had
not been there before
was, in some sense, a kind
of psychological element.
Even though in the
Astaire-Rogers films,
the singing and
dancing was still
in some sense much more central
to the film than the rest
of the story, and the stories
were often thin, what they did
introduce was an individuation.
In the Busby
Berkeley numbers, you
can see the women are--
all the characters in fact
are-- hard to differentiate
from the backdrop
or from the curtains.
They are objectified
in a certain way.
Especially when he
gets going, they
become parts of an
abstract pattern.
In the Astaire-Rogers films,
Astaire and Roger's characters
are deeply, sharply
individuated,
and certain kinds of
psychological themes
begin to enter in.
In this clip you're
going to see now,
a fairly characteristic one and
probably the single most famous
dance number in the
history of the studio era,
a dance number based on
the song "Cheek to Cheek,"
danced by Astaire and
Rogers-- in this sequence,
we are in a setting that's
worth mentioning to you.
We're on board a cruise ship.
Wealthy Americans are there.
It's wealthy
people, aristocrats.
The Astaire and Rogers
characters have met earlier,
and they haven't
really hit it off.
And the Rogers
character, the woman,
thinks that Fred Astaire is an
immoral man, that he commits
infidelities against his wife.
And she's under the
mistaken impression
that the woman he's
with is his wife.
So what happens in the
sequence, essentially,
is that in front of what
she believes to be his wife,
he asks her to dance-- he
asks Rogers to dance with her,
and then, to her surprise,
Astaire's apparent wife
says, oh, go ahead.
I'd love to see
you two together.
And she says, well, I'm--
and so when the dance begins,
she's sort of resistant.
She thinking, ah,
this is disgus--
and she goes along
with it, but she
feels there's something
wrong about it.
And then as the
dance goes on, you
can see her resistance
begin to break down.
And you can see the dance
becoming more and more mutual.
And you can see her enthusiasm
for the dance increase.
And think about what
the dance, first
of all, how profound
and brilliant this dance
is as an embodiment of
mutuality and collaboration
because one of the reasons
Rogers was so remarkable
was that she was
capable of dancing
at the same complex, astonishing
level as Fred Astaire himself.
And it's an image of mutuality
and of collaborative artistry
that's very remarkable.
But it's also a
metaphor for other kinds
of mutual interactions
that are physical.
And I hope you will pay
attention to that subtext
as you're watching this
remarkable sequence.
The fact that Rogers begins in
an act-- hostilely, resistant,
and yields slowly is a key
to the energy we see here.
OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Nice to see you
again, Miss Tremont.
DAVID THORBURN: Ginger Rogers.
-You've robbed me
of the pleasure
of introducing you two.
You've already met.
DAVID THORBURN: Now, remember,
Ginger is mistaken about this.
Fred's not really
married to her.
And of course that's a
typical Hollywood trick
because we're able
to enjoy the [FRENCH]
of infidelity and of the idea
of straying from your wife,
but it isn't really true.
-I don't know what
I'd do without her.
-Oh, that's sweet
of you, darling.
But you two run along and
dance, and don't give me
another thought.
-That's what I'm afraid of.
I think Madge is a
very brave person.
-Yes, I have tremendous
admiration for her.
DAVID THORBURN: You see
how the misunderstanding
adds tremendous sexual
energy, wit to the scene.
-Well, if Madge doesn't
care, I certainly don't.
-Neither do I. All I
know is that it's--
(SINGING) heaven.
I'm in heaven.
And my heart beats so
that I can hardly speak.
And I seem to find
the happiness I
seek when we're out together
dancing cheek to cheek.
Heaven, I'm in heaven.
DAVID THORBURN: Kristen,
can you put the sound off?
And pay attention--
[INAUDIBLE] I'm
going to do the
terrible damage to this.
Keep watching as I'm
talking, and imagine you
hearing the song, all right?
But because we're
running out of time,
I don't want to lose
our energy, and I
don't want to keep you over.
So this dance continues.
As you'll see, it's
quite a long sequence,
and he's singing to
her in his weedy--
really not a very
good singer, is he?
It doesn't seem to matter.
But one of the things
you should watch
is the way they move
out of a crowded space
into a more private space and
how the intimacy of their--
and how the dance partly
stops for a moment.
Then it resumes.
And they move-- as you'll
see in the sequence,
they move into a space that's
completely private, and her--
and if you watch
her expression, you
can also see that she's
beginning to yield,
that she's beginning
to become enthusiastic.
OK.
Put the sound back on.
-(SINGING) --charm about
you will carry me through
to heaven.
I'm in heaven.
And my heart beats so
that I can hardly speak.
And I seem to find
the happiness I
seek when we're out together
dancing cheek to cheek.
DAVID THORBURN: --the
sound for a second.
My final comment--
we're coming to
near the end of this sequence,
although it will extend.
I want you to hear
the music, too.
But watch especially the way
the intensity of this picks up
and then subsides.
Ask yourself what rhythms
are being implicitly
dramatized here and then
why, at the very end,
it's time for a cigarette.
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]